s'amuser
m
et de nouveaux donneurs
l'argent donne tout de suite c'est quoi
ces baskets n'était pas avec qui combien
temps des salles la regarder foulée des
ménages il lâché le de suite feu il a
rien on s'en va tu sais y sont plus
bêtes que méchants surviennent que nous
dit un peu inquiète pas on va te
protéger mais il pourra pas entrer dans
le collège comme ça ouais c'est vrai je
me de charges de sport ce que pour m
regarde non
voilà ça et tu mets ça
alors voilà
[Musique]
vous
je marchais
[Musique]
les tours qui jetaient jamais vu
on a trouvé devant le collège il est
enfin de se faire embêter par d
goûtez le stade très sympa et du coup on
a décidé de l'emmener dans le collège
veut qui comprend pas le français mais
surtout dit rien le père du soldat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est très utile a fait mal c'est de la
merde
pour insister pour la faire
voir ici tu vois c'est leur corps et âme
et regarde quand tu prends ton téléphone
et huppé que tu skies a eu accès à
toutes les informations sur la sur la
planche en question
adam nemec tunnel fatigué après un
naufrage de leur bateau
j'avais 21 ans
là pourquoi tu réponds jamais quand on
pose des questions tu parle pas français
meba
beaucoup
[Musique]
gâchis
c'est beau hein
ici et la cocoteraie l'ania les temps et
il ya même du rhône aix et us et là tu
es en train de marcher sur un ancien
chemin de fer
[Musique]
tu vois là dedans ils débouchent sur la
mer c
faux
[Musique]
ou alors c'est elle était toute à leur
insu c'est une collègue qui bien qu on a
des qualités salaire perdu aucune
énergie mois
salut alors savoir ce qu'on va faire
choper c'est sûr
feller trice des eaux notre ami ben
vas-y répond
[Musique]
baillargeon données sont nuls
mais pas de chance en plus il parle même
pas français
comment il va s'en sortir
[Musique]
e
on démarre aujourd'hui une nouvelle
leçon
on va démarrer pour aborder le racisme
une atteinte à la dignité humaine et
vous verrez que ce cours va se baser un
petit peu sur mon passé je suis donc
arrivé à la réunion il ya plus de vingt
ans j'ai un naufragé nous est donc un
immigré donc étranger pour la réunion et
pour la france
j'ai pu obtenir faire toutes les
démarches pour obtenir la citoyenneté
française pour pouvoir ensuite vivre
librement à la réunion
et pourquoi pas il travaille et c'est ce
que je fais aujourd'hui
[Musique]
mon